went back to tane and I was at roommate
he was like the [__] of the Frat he was
he was rushing frats just didn't really
come after me but the one that corded me
was one called deak and I was like let
me do some research shut down for
blackface at a
parade think I'm going to have to pass
on deep these guys are getting ready
they're like in the
mirror I'm going to look so good at the
Fourth of July parade so the Frat he
rushed was called Pike and they were
just dangerous they were like you tell
bad kids they were years later kids I
knew I saw them on CNN cuz they dumped
boiling water on a kid as hazing you
guys you guys know the funny prank you
guys know the funny prank where you give
a kid third degree burns yeah where you
treat a child like it's Siege Warfare in
the Middle Ages like he's a coac trying
to breach your walls and you pour
boiling water on him they they do softer
[__] guantan